Sydney harbour bridge builders frank miller
green carpenter. Do you member those
times do you mr belligerent over you. Well
there in january nineteen. That he and i
finished about september 1932 and was about
eight months after it opened. What was
your job. Exactly. I was a carpenter
a construction work. Form work during all
of rome work for the bridge approach. All
the concrete roads and the
parapet walls. They were made in
a factory underneath the bridge
on the north side. In the inner
workshop and they were sent there. I was
up in sections and we are erected on the
road where or wherever they had to go.
Was it hard work very hard work as way
things were very hard and those days because
the depression was all over. Well on
and everybody up the end of days. Worked.
And there was no life and then i can say
there's that for all the years
we were there was never
a strike or ever in the industrial double
except for those that work for doing one
longs they struck the little while the
high money which they got i think they got
six times. On our money. How many carpenters
were you working on the approaches at
the north side. Well i can't imagine i can't
tell you really but they were only in
the hundreds hundreds of them our
engineer headman and i'll supervisor.
Say it was mr.
Roper. I think you enjoy pretty was named
and foreman and there was ted ledbury
and then of course
a couple awaiting him in charge of different
gangs. We were all in sections. I
worked on the north side exclusively on the
ground then from the station more and.
No certainly staged and then mills and bowen
station which was known as cura billy
station on them. Those then that
james do you remember you had
a in one gang. How many countries where
then how many labourers be about twenty and
some time one number of libraries because
i know i have to be handled manually.
There were any crimes ending like
a lift anything is that we
really just manhandled in
a truck something like that and barrows
but and all the work was done by him. It
was no machine. Experience even when the
current great was probably there was no
ready mix concrete and days it was all done
by big mixes concrete mixers which held
a cubic yard
a concrete they were big ones i think there
were about twelve of them and they were
down at the bottom on the ground level
and the concrete was mixed there.
Make there's
a through you know by the
papers that the crushed spoil
from mariah carey was crushed in the current
grate and that comprise the metal part
of the concrete they were mixed and
they were put in a vehicle called
a rickshaw which was
a v-shaped truck with big world
as they were soon as a send up by
a lift up onto the landing and that
was run along on the track barges
a two men push of the long and that's how
the concrete was bought with our buy
everything was done by him with all those
work. How many country can do you think
there were ten. Yes there would
be ten then things. It was
a continual more as it kept going until
of thing was poor. They didn't write the
columns of the buttresses that held the
road where. They were built. First of
course and. They had some sailboats
and them which were used for
lifting us scaffold up. That's our
framework was in and then we they were in
cardboard container tubes and they
were pulled out when the. How
was on and when they when the lift of
our they were taken out and how the
timber frame where of the foam worked.
They were they were put in the game to out
the framework together and that's out the
thing was build up so it was more or less
at its. Ascending. Type
of scaffolding that was
a modern sort of idea for those days when
it was years because they used everybody
is there a big braces and
traps and things but this was
a very good idea and those marks are still
on the brown they would but if someone
went to look we have the house
were there with the tube and
the long brown through as they are about
three feet now about three. And they print
projected so far some more timber up
there. Well if they have the mills and the
rain where got. There's
a very neat you know who was responsible
for that system. Now i don't because it
started when i got air but i don't know
i was in charge of it but mr wright was
like the engineer in charge of
construction i'm over there and he was
a rather clever man and that may have been
his or their do you remember the overall
form and their. Our overall warming of our
games. You know it was them generally
but with ted ledbury he was
a great big that of alan. I'm very
content you do. By the way very stern
a very strict we did and he did it at all
although many years after i met him in
the public works where i work from twenty
one years later on and we become the best
of friends. He's dead now. For exactly.
Do you remember the general public works
for him and then the shepherd.
Here's there and he was
a little chap
a small very small mountain
stages but he was very
well very popular among the
people there don't try
a side or as some of them and you got the
sack straightaway. Who. What about him
did what stories were there to
tell about him was he was he
a hard man. Well it was very very strict
and if he didn't like the look in your
face if you went. That was all i can say
about him i wouldn't say any more. That's
a pity. And there was
a couple of accusations made on the approaches
of. Blokes in authority asking for.
For something at the fella's wages of the
firm. You never hear anything like that.
Yes i did hear that was one of them but
because i know want to speak about the
people probably a bit but.
There was a lot of tories
a groom one of very pleasant valley. We'll
remember how you first got the job as
a cup draw the approaches to. Yes well
things were very bad at that time and we
were on. On the dole as a no and there was
a call up in the pipe of no some none
when twelve hundred carpenters wanted
and we got the report of the key labor
bureau station at circular quay.
I went down my number was
fourteen hundred. But making
a return so yeah we had
we were supposed to have
a look. Preppers that went down there at
about eleven o'clock after the riots and
trouble and all that was over. And i saw
the chap on the counter and i gave him
a card and said can you do anything
with this. He's a liar you're a bit of
a no he said but when i mean it is
a neural digger i said you first were bigger
these are coming. So i took me in the
weather room where the dead man was it was
a very hard man to deal with to get his
name and he looked me up and down these
were sort of a garden and i was
a mobile you good guy and now he said
what's all the work you do i think if you
want to work like i said fixing work
journey where roofing current great.
Anything you want i can do it and
he said can you work up against
a man on the bridge on the bench. I said
yes. Journey work. I said yeah i know all
about it. And he said well
they weren't joiners over the
bridge. I know he found it because because
that was the job of jobs. So he gave me
a ticket to go over there and i went home
and the ferry makes mining the great big
box of true joiners. And worked about half
a mile to the headquarters where they
joined the shop whereas i asked for the
foreman join in and i said i've
been told to come in for a job is
a lie don't want to me during these alarms
all of them now is packed and they eyes
but i'm. I want to make 100 men. Why didn't
they tell me i think that's when i am
like you can't read word. I just finished
three years with power hours where i was
as
a carpenter out there that was all trump
great work so he set me up to the. Ted
ledbury was a foreman and that's
how i started i only died with
a pose that they didn't want joiners job
gone. So i would have very pleased to get
out there and we were very grateful for
that job but i was lucky enough to last.
Just on three years on the job. So that
was relief work here. Was it always that
full time work. We're russian that
time i just started the rationing days
a week we worked for four days
a week and i think my money was about
four pound and twopence a week for
a day's work. They did that to. Spread
the work out and give more people work.
There was a good idea. Well yes i did i
think the home. Leave and everybody having
a share of the cake and i gave them
a few more people some work i was able
to keep two families going then and. You
know keep us in food and well what
have you and that for a pound
a week covered as on there
is days. Things are
a lot cheaper and them though they are now
keeping two families going. You wouldn't
have to was that you know i my brother and
i was out of work when his girl baby and
we had one and my baby only little kiddies
and i don't mind do it was only two year
old and i don't. And she well as
a bridge and. We were labeled i was
able to provide for both of us
three years. This is quite something
before that we were on the delta how long.
Well grateful that i was lucky i had been
working at sort of steady counsel had
done wrong paras i was there for three years
for nineteen the end of 1929 and then
in january thirty one thirty. I got the
job on the bridge. So i never felt the
depression really until the end of the
thirty two but i really felt that after that
. Thirty four. It was
a very grim. When the dole and we're right
on the dole yes they were very hard. We
finished up being put on relief work on
live on hurstville and not as that my place
is
a big storm or the channel and they made
us work for our money then we work so many
hours
a week on great work over there and. I was
you know again i'm trying to write what
i was there till 1934. But it didn't amount
to much of the amount of dough about
sixteen shillings a week as what we got and
it was called relief work was that was
a relief work they started that everybody
was you know it bank managers and clerks
and everything british people as they some
of the poor fellows trying to shovel mud
out of these slimy. Snow more
that you know not canals
and went right from pinned down to beverly
hills where i lived there and in fact
the passes my door. The storm or the
canal. There were many of those jobs going
where there. Well the every district had
it all gender barrier and no other part of
it. They call muddy creek and
down down the ground. There's
a big wide one down there and over to
it's canterbury and there's a big one
a very wide one over there and it spreads
all over the metropolitan area as the
liberal party were in power at that
time that they got rid of jack land and
unfortunately and they. They started to put
that stuff on to make it work for your
money but. Webs our things were done.
While you were working on the bridge you
remember any accidents that happened down
there. Well not personally not near me
and not on the plane approaches they were
many many of their odd ones. Dressed
a bank or something like
that where a slip with
a barrow. But i saw the one the
one when i nearly saw i saw
a near or part of it at the jap that
recovered from an accident. I think his name
was kili. It was
a reagan and he fell off the deck which
is one hundred ninety nine feet above sea
level. And they're about that and i'd say
out of the tops about one hundred four
hundred two feet above sea level. I live
fell off the level of the deck but being
you know. I'm experienced
swimmer and either
a new out of all in the world. I mean
certainly you know the prelims all round to
go for it. Held exams over the
years ahead which i yesterday was
a day over there myself and the end of the
water was strong and honest. And there
he came down. He came up these went to
about nearby and they want to go back to
work. They wouldn't let him go back there
made it go home at the aftershock my
lappets upset him however he was one of
the very few that recovered from that
accident. There was one carpenter killed
on the approaches in the fitzroy she went
there then. No i didn't. Now that that's
why i was that north sydney. Yes there was
a collapse there shattering collapsed and
a car went down and killed. That's right.
I can remember that i'd only meant that
jap get and i could have remembered it
was just now is my problem. My memory. I
used to when they were putting the shutters
on the road which is three foot thick.
I always had the job. Of being on the
scaffold under me with an oilskin and
sou'wester hat on and
a big spanner looking at the door of the
concrete and making sure that nothing
collapsed and nothing went wrong and
i had to collapse and i had a i had
a bell. I can ring. If anything happened
during that bell and we used to stop
the poor come and fix the fault but there
was never any fall while i was doing it.
I done that tactically every problem that
i was worked on. I work there is to get
an hour extra for wet money for doing
that and i hope that what your as
a crime prove that there was no collapse
or damage done to the storm where some of
those arches there know sydney particularly
fitzroy street and levon the street
which are going to go arches they were they
were they were big big slabs. They were
well constructed. Because the
reinforcing of those roads. Are as j's
right around steel joists and their
two foot six high wide and long
and twelve inches wide and they were placed
three inches apart from each other and
they were three inches up from the bottom
and three inches down from the top and
all the rest was pure concrete went into
them and that's what all along that road
where bill got right. Because i was there
while they were doing it. That was an
expensive way to build
a road. It's it may be but now we're just
ordinary reinforcing its solid royals
round steel joists and there we have forever
that road will never go impossible.
There are about thirty odd feet wide. I
think between each buttress. And they were
arresting them they were about two feet at
the top and about three or four feet at
the bottom type but then after the bridge
was finished rebuild shops under them and
lined i haven't of
a road side. We built shops and the
government got it. The least amount
due to member. The day that they've got the
record for pouring the lavender street
shrink 500 cubic yards in
the one day where there was
a well that was done. You know i may have
been part of it. I don't know whether i
was in that gang but we were all separate
gang were mixed around. But i remember i
was there that day one when
that was done that was
a very good. They were late to get it all
down. Never stop the poor ones those
don't know that those they kept would
go on and. The parapets of course
were built after the floor was there
were the road workers there and that was
another set of. For my work. That's all.
And that pattern continues right through
the bridge from the north to those outside
that was owned by going to plaster isn't
it will go and buy carpenters first with
form work and then they would it was
rendered over by plasters and each in
its batteries has got an expansion
joint of three inches of pitch
and cork mixed together and as
we put
a slab in one section. We take the end
section off from work and then nail this
section of the bitumen do it and that was
an expansion you know and i've seen it in
the summertime about an inch wide and then
the wintertime three inches wide. That's
the expanse of concrete. That was done
right through the bridge. That there's
northern approaches were done in just
over two years when they didn't take
a long time now but two years i was there
the rest of that time we built the
station i worked on nelson torrens station.
Used to be killer billy station and i
think. The rich people out there didn't
like the name and they made them change it
. My companion my mate and i and we
fixed out the station like putting the
doors and windows in the states and those
they are they the same set of doors
and windows because i had a look at them
a little while ago and went by accident to
cross the bridge on the train. And they
had
a look at my own work and it was still there
still working the doors and windows are
still over fifty years ago. That's good
work. You know you can't quite remember how
many gangs of carpenters they were now i
don't i didn't take much notice and them
david we're only concerned with our own
little group and we were in mirror i
wouldn't know our money they were as i
know there were hundreds hundreds of men
working on it and you think there was about
ten concrete mixers. Yes at least ten
great mixers ten or twelve grand great
mixers up to the northern end up near
north sydney station and they were all
their group there and they used to have
a hoist take about the
top and then the men
a library wheeled among tourists and july
came to their position and then they
provided more of
a crime green then they had men stirring
and up shovel agitating it so they
don't even really make them to make their
concrete park as you know we've got one
bloke with a concrete pack as
they crawl and. There was never
a relation in those days. No there was no
vibrators like they've got now and there
is no ready god right now. It was all done
by hand. Now as i was interested in the
contrast between the way diamond lung did
things and the way the public works did
things dome and long had only one concrete
mixer for each pylon and one concrete
mixing gang and they were away for eight
years whereas the public works had ten or
fifteen whole lot only
a short period of time did they they got
stuck in there with that's why they called
out all the carpenters because carpenters
they used to that sort of work is not
a labor of job putting
formwork down the top was
a tried job and it happened very
properly done because that meant a meant
a big thing because you know what you were
doing. Yeah. And everybody up into it
all. Dr.
Bradfield was very friendly man he often
used to walk across the way where we were
working so good
a boys out there and we all drove him doc.
We all liked we were very friendly even
have a laugh and a joke with
us. Keep the good work needs
a and we were all alive. They were weird
you were getting into it. Nobody liked in
them days. You did you could not vote
because you know that jobs were jobs
and the other engineers had you
done with them. Alright. Yes mr.
Roper was
a very friendly man too. I remember one
incident when. They just before finished
they the first official tried went across
the bridge. And my mate was named jack
costigan i think he's dead now. We
were working on breaking the handrail
down the eggs it part of the
station and they had all the
government heads and departments and
then get ready to go under those you'd
photographed. The first official train.